by the power of castle hate skull i
am hello mark harley and you are in for
a special special episode this is
episode number 20. so what are we gonna
do we're gonna take a shot to celebrate
on camera tiger thick whiskey oh yeah
here we go
is this a shot i don't know because i
don't really do a little bit more
because i'm a sizable human being
live taste test we'll see how this turns
out and christian's also taking some
casey has a job
unlike us
with responsibilities okay here we go
three two one
i'm so drunk right now
um
delish and now again i'm faded so
you guys see me in the man but this is
how i came out of the shower after
working out i did a run today
i did my little hill run 2.2 miles from
the bottom of ventura
up to mulholland and i just wanted to
say every time i do this it's always
hard and especially as i gain muscle it
actually gets harder i wanted to
encourage you guys to do [ __ ] that sucks
because
i get up in the morning and i plan to do
it i'm like i love to work out before i
do the podcast i don't always get a
chance to because i'm still preparing in
the morning and looking up clips and
thinking about things that i want to
present to you guys but if i do it a god
damn it puts me in a good mood so
i am
feeling good and i also like to drink
after i've actually
done some workouts like if i've done
something physical in the day it just
feels a lot better i don't like to just
drink to make myself feel good and i
rarely drink anyway so i'll probably be
uh doing you know i'll probably be
feeling just that one shot on camera i
wanted
to start off today with halimark hair
tips this is the first time we're ever
doing this but sometimes people will ask
me like what do you do for your hair a
bunch of different stuff i'm always
trying stuff but like
mainly i wash it not a lot because that
kind of adds some texture and volume to
this but let's say
this is me getting out of the shower had
i wanted to get ready
for the podcast again this is like
working out showering what i'll do is
super simple stuff
dry shampoo all right
you put it in here you put it in your
roots
you spray it in here
and i used to look at
girls do this i'm like oh my god dry
shampoo that's the lamest thing ever
like obviously shampoo can't be dry like
what are you doing it just smells like
[ __ ]
what it does though
is adds texture
and volume then you comb it in a little
bit
can you believe this dude i'm doing this
free ball
are you a little bit out of breath doing
this right now like what what's going on
i thought you were in shape
yeah sorry not everyone's a tough mudder
winner
not everyone's a cardio king
like the most handsome podcast producer
on the internet and then we do a little
bit of this this is actually some
awapuhi i think is how it's said spelled
pronounced
third time's the term you're wasted oh
well exactly i'm drunk everything i mess
up with this episode i'm drunk it's a
hydro mist blowout spray so you can add
heat to this and it works and it kind of
creates volume but also like if you want
to create a little bit of a
like wet look that you can comb into
um
and it adds like a tiny little bit of
hold and kind of like
just dries with a little bit of
something so you'll add this and just
you know
i'm combing it halfway through
i cannot see what's going on but that's
okay because again most of my hairstyle
is kind of messy anyway so
these are two little helmet hair tips
for you to take with you especially
because most guys with long hair like
the struggle is
how do i get volume how do i
you know get it to not look like
thin and shitty and too flat and
for many years i didn't know what the
hell to do with my hair and i'm just
kind of figuring that but i will
experiment with products like clays and
hairsprays and
mooses and mises and stuff like that all
right
so
first of all you saw the shirt that i
just put on the tough mudder
yes i did the tough mudder
my prediction beforehand what did i say
christian
i thought you would win
but i also said i did say
um both of you guys i was like i think
the short guys are gonna do better the
short kings are gonna have a good
showing so i was half right in the sense
that casey smoked everybody you stayed
with chappelle and jay
right uh but you know i was actually
kind of validating to see you at the end
because i had the same experience that
you did which was like being near
hypothermic yeah like i was shivering
and for i couldn't feel my hands
throughout the whole thing
it was tough it was yeah that was the
toughest part of the tough mudder
especially because it was so wet
like
you know it's it's whatever 50 degrees
and the
the obstacles were all
water-based
more so than the last time i wasn't
expecting this much
and it's hard to heat up get your body
temperature up or really you know
when you're looking at the veins in your
hands and i took an emergency adderall
beforehand which was a bad idea because
i'm feeling groggy in the morning i'm
like i know i'll just take an adderall
to kind of get myself up do not do that
before any exercise i cannot
dissuade you enough from taking adderall
because as a vasoconstrictor
and i guess especially in cold um
because it makes blood flow to these
areas to your extremities uh much worse
so the whole time i was like you know
like it it brought me out of that funk
that i felt in the morning and i just
wanted to like get up and kind of feel
some energy
but then during the thing i'm like god
damn i can't like get blood flow to my
hands
so
that part was rough
uh the coolest part of it
was the fact that afterwards
they had all these cans of rain
afterwards i felt like i was in a dream
or something like you ever have a dream
where you like find something like oh my
god like as a kid i would sound stupid
but i used to have dreams that i
would find a bunch of frogs i was
obsessed with frogs as a kid and i'd
like like have like buckets you know
stumble upon some creek and it's like oh
my god there's frogs everywhere i'm
gonna have a million pet frogs that was
like this at the end of the tough mudder
there was buckets of of rain that they
left out so i literally just filled my
backpack with like 30 cans of rain and
i'm like carrying it out you know
weighing 80 pounds
um casey you also saw me eat for the
first time
if you want to call that eating that was
that was binge consumption dude
that was and i try not to do that
anymore but i was like
really hungry afterwards and i was like
you know you get something in your head
i guess this is like part of binge
eating so i'm about to be like you know
when but i'm like i think normal people
don't do this where you see something
and you're like well i have to eat that
like i had it in my head that i was
gonna also eat the nachos you know to
your defense all the food trucks were
dope like everything i could see being
like i gotta try all this stuff plus we
just ran 10 miles did all this yeah like
you kind of earned it yeah so you know
that's where it starts it's like i
earned something right and i think
that's a
generally a dangerous thing when you're
dieting it's like the idea of earning
you know because it's like you can you
can go like
like do a 10 minute run and be like i
earned this 800 calorie dessert you know
um or even worse but so starting with
the earning stuff can kind of be a
slippery slope
but i think i ate from like three or
four different food trucks and i was
gonna stop and then like there was one
food truck where the guy was like oh
this guy knows you from the you know the
fighter and the kid and he wants to give
you these nachos and i'm like well i
can't turn that down obviously and that
was like the last thing that i actually
was eating in my car on the way home
after i had like you know the texas like
barbecue cheeseburger and like multiple
hot dogs and a uh
what's the funnel cake thing so i was
like at least three or four items
and then he hit me with these carne
asada nachos that like i just didn't
want to pass up the opportunity of free
food he was like i'll make this for you
and everything was kind of expensive you
know it's like airbnb oh i didn't know
it was free that's a horse of a
different color yeah no you're right
yeah you gotta eat it at that point yeah
so
uh on the way home actually i was like
eating it and i'm like god i'm so
[ __ ] full like i wanted to throw it
out the window like to like stop like
looking at and having in there and i
didn't because i think
that's [ __ ] up to like just throw
nachos out the window uh but at some
point i had to hit the brakes really
hard i was like taking an exit it was
like all backed up and they flew off my
seat
because i was sitting there like
snacking on them and like had the moment
of like i'm totally stuffed to the point
of like being super uncomfortable yet
i'm still eating these like that's why i
want to throw them out the window and
then i didn't and then they like flew
all over the front seat so now like the
whole you know
my whole prius is smelling like nachos
and uh the disgusting clothes i was in
no oh i wanted to show you these so i
threw my athletic shoes away
that needed to be thrown away
and then i i need to get some new ones i
was like costco
i love costco so much i didn't even know
they sold shoes like i had a general
idea you know that you're like i guess
costco sells shoes but these are 25 they
only come in size 12 and 13 which is a
weird thing
it's like we got one size of a shoe
basically um
but uh you know these are like fully
functional it's just impressive because
that's what i when i have like running
shoes i'm like i'm not gonna buy like
the super expensive ones i just don't
like even though i do you know
potentially run a lot in a given week um
you know 50 bucks is like my lemon right
you go to this like whatever you can get
like decent shoes for 50 or 60 bucks and
these were 25 bucks so i bought two of
them so now i can [ __ ] these up
and just throw them away and be less
attached to them because that's the
other thing too is like
a lot of guys i know like run shoes into
the ground of the course of years
and uh never swap out their shoes and
you talk to like a cross country runner
and they're like yeah i'd like change
shoes every month
you know like that's
like oh [ __ ] so these shoes that i
bought in 2012 should like go up the
door now you think um but casey so you
were the first
of the fit crew
to win but you don't really run what do
you do to keep in shape uh i do crossfit
oh but i just i just do it at home like
uh yeah i mean i started back in like
2008 yeah um so at this point
uh i don't follow a program i just go
based on feel whatever i feel like doing
that day and i just do it at home and i
kind of at this point just do like a
watered down version of it yeah um so i
don't go crazy but yeah i just have like
a bar belts i have a barbell oh nice
kettlebell yeah pull up bar and rings oh
nice yeah that is really good and i
probably i've talked about this before
like how i did my own kind of
watered-down version of crossfit with uh
where i'd go just fine i'd be like what
is free at the 24-hour fitness when i
walk in and base my workout around
um you know a barbell or a pair of
dumbbells or a kettlebell and doing a
full body circuit that would have some
sort of push-pull like squat hinge ab
movement yeah and it kind of i think
that like starts to look like crossfit
yeah i basically just have like i'll do
like a deadlift day or squat day and a
press day and then mix those movements
with one body weight movement so i'm
literally only doing like two movements
a day yeah and you know do like an imam
or just like it's an amrap in 10 minutes
yeah right because you can really [ __ ]
yourself up in you know it's like do
this hard thing every minute on the
minute yeah you know do like
five cleans on the minute or something
like that it's like first of all you're
not gonna get that much rest so it's
like you know maybe you're getting 30 or
40 seconds rest
if that
but doing that 10 times in a row is very
high intensity
and the interesting thing i think
because you're saying you don't run that
translates oh that translates to running
versus like if you were just to run
yeah you'd come to crossfit and be
shocked at how difficult it was
um but doing those short bursts of
activity i've always felt like well yeah
i can like you know if i'm doing like 10
minutes of high intensity i can run an
hour yeah and i've never i i don't run i
haven't run
far in a long time the most the furthest
i've ever run is probably a 10k so i've
never even run this distance ever in my
life yeah
yeah so that's it's a testament to as
much as people give crossfit
[ __ ] it's like well it does get you in
shape yeah you know on the fringes of
things like make fun of the pull-up
technique or the uh
you know the fact that people get
injured doing
olympic lifting which is very complex
and technical but if you're just looking
for a hard-ass workout like it's it's to
me it's it's one of the best ways to
just go kick your own ass
now speaking of
workout styles a bunch of you asked for
the dc programs i sent out a lot
now i am actually manually entering
everybody's email address and send it to
me it's easier if you send me
a separate message like if you say hey
i'd like the program and then in a
different message put your email address
because then i can just copy and paste
that and put it in there but i'm
diligently working on that hopefully by
the time you see this everybody who has
asked for the dc program
uh will have gotten one and i love the
fact that you guys have actually reached
out because it's a cool way for me to
like provide value like hey here's
something that i can
you know spend a couple hours to get
into all these different people it's
something that i already put time doing
and i just really like dc programming
because again
any kind of
high intensity low volume really shows
that you don't have to do that much
in order to get results
and like if your only goal is
hypertrophy and maybe
weight loss like
i really like crossfit style stuff as
we're talking about because it like
you'll feel like holy [ __ ] i got my ass
kicked at the end of it and like you're
getting all these different modalities
if you're just looking for the most
efficient way to put on muscle
i think most people don't understand how
like little time you have to spend to
actually put on muscle um especially if
you're de-trained or you're a beginner
or whatever but even if you're advanced
you can you know some i've been sending
out advanced protocol videos
uh links to that this guy dusty hanshaw
has these amazing videos
uh with regards to dc training so you
can see it in action because i think
it's one thing to describe it but it's
like you want to see somebody actually
going to like all out failure okay
now bunch you also
wanted me to do dmt this week and i
wanted to i had it my friend actually
bought a dmt pen the time that we did it
in those trailers in joshua tree which
i'm forgetting the name of again
hicksville trailer park that's what it
is
uh we me and my buddy cameron and his
friend alex who i met who's a great guy
we like all went in on a dmt pen
and we're like we're gonna do this like
you know several times a year now i have
not gotten back together with them to do
dmt but the one time i'm like hey
cameron do you have the dmt bed like
who's got it he's like alex does and i'm
like and let me guess he's not in l.a
he's like nope he's in sacramento so i
was going to get it from him i didn't
but i'm going to figure out how to get a
dmt pen because i want to do it because
you guys are interested in it now it
might be boring because i'm going to sit
there and you know freak out inside my
own head for a few minutes but i at
least want to at least want to report
you know maybe we'll film it and be like
all right cut out all the you know 10
minutes of me like silently twitching
and i'll just tell you what i
experienced afterwards but uh it seems
like you guys are interested in that and
i want to do that i also want to do like
this was like you know taking the shot
i'm like
so in case you're in the way of where
i'm like it's gonna become a
recreational drug podcast isn't it
that's okay i'll at least do micro
dosing of psychedelics i think that's
interesting so i can kind of report to
you because one of the big things about
psychedelics is like
people have this
idea that it's scarier than it is any
time i talk i've talked to people who'd
actually taken dmt and they're like but
lsd is so scary i'm like no it's not at
all so i just want to show you that
again like anabolics it's dose
proportionate
and taking a microdose is a really safe
way to ensure at least that you're not
getting
like these scary side effects i'm also
going to go into in a little bit if we
have time
because i always have like 30 segments i
want to do
my first time taking lsd now
what up
what else is up with me inseparable oh
can we click on this little link above
there there we go
worked out with this guy's an ifbb pro
he hit me up to work out of zoo culture
really great guy
uh julian puccio and his girlfriend
karina
you know and i'm just saying this
because first i want to point out like
this guy's a [ __ ] bodybuilder like
look at this look at this frame look at
these broad shoulders
look at how dramatic his physique is so
he's like a men's physique champion it's
just crazy like that's the smallest
version of a bodybuilder is like men's
physique and i think you could gain
weight and go up to classic but like
he's uh about as tall as i may be a
little bit taller but the dude's like
just broader than me and uh and stronger
than me and he's in the lowest class of
like you know men's physique where they
wear board shorts and it's kind of like
these are the small guys and it's like
yeah you should be the student person
he's like
six three six four two fifty
um and just has that really
broad frame i think that translates well
to a bodybuilding stage where your
shoulders are really big and your pecs
and kind of lats like fill out you know
on that frame and i'm also telling you
this because people hit me up like let's
get a lifted zoo culture i'm like yeah
we can do it if you're serious like we
could do it um if you know what you're
doing and it's not like me giving you a
personal training session which even
then i guess i could do that but
i'm in the ballpark of this guy's
strength he's stronger than me but um
you know it's just easier to work out i
think with people who are like kind of
roughly in that same
limit but either way i think it's really
cool to connect with random people who
are in town and just be like yo let's do
it and that's my favorite way like
rather than getting coffee or
getting drinks
which could be cool too but
i like uh i like working out with people
and connecting that way had a cool
message this will be the last thing i
think for sup fool
you know cause i get messages like this
i know i talk about haters all the time
and people misconstrue that as like
you know you obsessed with haters this
whole show is about haters and i'm like
you've never watched an episode then
because it's not all about haters
it's about having an interactive fun
community and uh connecting with people
like i do with this dc training thing
sending you guys out and trying to
respond to comments so this guy hit me
up he said mr harley i'd like to thank
you for keeping me
going with the laughs on a daily basis
over the past two years my family has
been dealt a tough hand cancer times two
my wife's dad was diagnosed with
dementia and early alzheimer's then to
top it all off the universe decided we
needed a giant [ __ ] you when i lost my
dad on easter sunday i've had some
extremely dark days which i guess is to
be expected after losing a parent my
wife has always said that laughter heals
me better than any therapy or medicine i
could ever buy you sir have been a daily
source of smiles and an escape from my
depression i know there's a million
sources of memes and jokes out there but
for some reason your perspective always
has me rolling i'm sure you uh this will
get lost in the myriad of messages you
get on a daily basis if you do in fact
see this know that you have a big fan
that is extremely grateful for the
content you provide the masses on social
media cheers like how cool is that
somebody reaches out and like i am of
course like immediately like you're oh
god that is a lot to deal with in a year
uh the death of you know a parent and of
course that's always just gonna rock
your world uh
alzheimer's too because that's not
something like you know unlike death
it's like there's a lot to deal with
with death but it's final and dimension
alzheimer's is something where you're
watching somebody
uh
you know slip away you don't know that
person anymore and it's just really
difficult and frustrating to deal with
and just to me one of the darkest things
you can deal with because
you're actually
dealing with somebody who's forgetting
who you are a loved one who's slowly
changing in front of your eyes
forgetting who you are and those
memories you know you can see slipping
away and and they become mean
potentially to you and their personality
changes because their brain is
degenerating and you know that's an
interesting topic in and of itself
because i would like to have a lot of
things uh you know i like they say that
alzheimer's and dementia can be like
diabetes of the mind and um and exercise
is one of the things that really helps
prevent that and so that's you know one
of the big reasons i lift
of course i like to look good but if you
can get yourself exercising and keep
that up on the long term you're greatly
reducing from what i understand your
chances of catching dementia and
alzheimer's and it's just devastating
for you obviously and the people
around you so man i cuz that's just one
of the scariest things to me is is to
you know and of course everybody has
cognitive decline at some point donald
trump joe biden but like
you know it's just you you would hope
that uh people would limit that um you
know or at least kill yourself if you're
going down that route i'm sorry i'm
being a dick
but but that's what i think it's okay
remember you're drunk
that's true but no i think that's like
one of the few things where i'm like
if i started to like realize like i'm
like oh i'm forgetting everything like
time to end it you know oh mark oh come
on
come on like mark your memory issues
aren't that bad yeah did you ask me this
morning if we had already done a segment
that you want to do potentially
so you know go easy that's an amazing
callback casey just called me out for
not remembering what i do on my own show
within the past two weeks
oh my god um
so i'll just read my response real quick
man i'm really sorry to hear about all
that tragedy and untimely death that has
struck your family recently it really
warms my heart to know that i could give
a small contribution to your efforts to
navigate and process all those extremely
difficult times and yes there are
certainly a lot of places online you can
get memes from which makes it really
cool that for whatever reason you sought
out my page for that kind of short term
entertainment curation a lot of people
will question why i post so many memes
but one message like this justified all
the time that i've ever spent doing it
which is true
i hope you have an amazing rest your day
and the 2022 brings you lots of joy and
reason to celebrate so that's all true
from my end is like you know we put so
many
well if you get anything out of it it
gives you five minutes of reprieve from
all the [ __ ] that you're going through
then i think it's all worth it and and
it is this little quick easy way to be
like hey i thought this was funny do you
think this is funny cool we just made a
connection our brains are linked hashtag
neural link
everybody commented on the picture i
posted with julian saying he looked like
elon musk isn't that a cool thing with
guys that we just don't even give a [ __ ]
we're like i'm gonna post the joke for
the 800th time i'm not even gonna look
and even if i did look
i'm still gonna post it
people elon musk elon musk if you said
elon muskel
good for you somebody said uh tip of the
finger comedy said elon buff i was like
okay now we're now we're working with
some puns here okay
you can always come clever you can
always come original even if you're
making a similar observation
man oh man cool stuff i saw on the
internet this week
there's this trend um
of making influencers fat look at this
crisp upstairs
i don't know why i get such a kick out
of this now it was originally done by
more tran more men
which is a parody account of more plates
more dates and so he was making like fat
derrick for more plates more dates but
isn't that [ __ ] cute i don't know
let's click on the next link there's one
more that's uh
i think it's fat
greg
[Laughter]
it's amazing how terrible people look
you just add a fat face and you're like
you look
absolutely atrocious
so
that's one of those things that i pay
attention to like when i start to gain
weight i'm like oh my face looks
terrible
not worth it even though there was a
time in my life where like i used to
look at power lifters like when i was in
high school in college i want to be this
big jack
like puffy dude
um
and thought that was cool but really the
thing that goes first is your face you
just look like absolute garbage is there
a link under there that we can click on
oh can we turn the volume on for this
oh my god
is this this random camera angle and
there's conor mcgregor
and we just hear like him moaning and
like
and he's eating like a mr goodbar or
something like that
how far gone is this dude i saw somebody
caption like when you you know
one hour earlier these edibles ain't
[ __ ]
so he's just literally like cracking
himself up could we just play that one
more time
um because he's like filming i had no
the best thing is i had no idea who this
was
and then it's just like
he's mmm he's moaning to himself
[Laughter]
his eyes are glad he knows like what's
the reveal is conor mcgregor that we're
all going to be laughing at him okay
what's the next one that i had there
go easy on them also i mean last week we
went we went in deep on sprinkles i mean
guys just enjoying an ice cream bar i
think we've all been there
oh my goodness massive conor mcgregor
fan if you can't tell
yeah i think it's hilarious i mean he
doesn't seem like he's gonna fight when
i see
videos like that okay this is my mom
i know it's not my mom but god damn
people who send me things that like
you're like oh this is you and sometimes
it's just some like random old dude with
gray hair and it's not complimentary at
all but like you know
this is a [ __ ] or older woman so i'm
gonna take this as a compliment congrats
i forget who posts who tagged me and
people tagged me and stuff all the time
this one is actually worthwhile okay and
then there's one more isn't there let's
see what it is
oh
yeah i i'd [ __ ] my mom and she looked
like that whoa edit that out um
you're wasted this is really cool
because this is a uh
this a dude
painting like a
you know sock drawer type of thing he's
putting all these glazes and you're like
what is he doing
uh you know first it looks like he's
painting a butterfly then he sees paint
to this koi fish and he keeps putting
these layers of gloss over and over and
over uh between each layer and you're
wondering why he's doing that after by
the way uh singeing you know burning the
box that he's putting it in
the individual cabinet
but as he's putting this detail on
you're like oh my god this is
hyper realistic
and eventually you see
what the finished product is you put
these little brackets on and uh he's
going to turn it over in a second and
you'll see
that it looks three-dimensional like
holy [ __ ] it's all glossy and it looks
like these are actual 3d fish underwater
so
that's a cool thing that you can put
socks in
you're gonna buy a thousand dollar uh
piece of handcrafted art to put your
panties in all right we got the liver
king meme of the week we're not gonna
stop with this now
first i wanna let's click on that link
because this is the setup actually to
the meme
uh he posted a video if we could get
some audio on that he's talking about
what he's going to eat
for dinner we have a whole beef protein
shake we have a whole big protein
chicken
liver
we're going to have this pure marrow
right out of the femur we have about
four to six ounces of turkey hearts we
have my daily serving of vegetables
turkey hearts a beef protein shake which
sounds disgusting
because we earned it we have one pound
of ground beast
with some chicken hearts chicken horse
right
and then we're going to be really eating
all that food
and i think that about like i get to
like like let's eat some liver and
vitamin raw liver but this is like
pounds of food
a little bit of olive oil and he puts
maple syrup in olive oil that's news to
me as well i didn't know that he was
like washing it all down he's like i'm
gonna eat a beef testicles and wash it
all down with
maple syrup
okay so then this guy posted this meme
that's a picture of him in that same
video in the caption as liver king here
today for lunch i'm skipping the liver
and going straight in on this chinese
nazi assortment of dry aged foreskins
nobody ever tells you that the best part
is cutting them off with a dick yourself
if you're not getting your dry aged
cock's hole you're not a real foreskin
fanatic
foreskins are a flavorful whole food
that you need in your diet if you want a
body like this and to be in touch with
your ancient primal ancestors but you
don't have the foreskins of your enemies
as a regular member of your diet quit
kidding yourself
oh my goodness
okay
and uh and then we'll do one more that
link right there that's uh
i am doing handstand push-ups in front
of a tank i just like honestly this
guy's so entertaining to me
like where does he where i don't i don't
even know what the backstory is but it's
just like
he's just
everything he posts is just so random
and like
just handstand push-ups in front of a
tank there we go
because why not
and it makes it seem like this is just
part of my normal day you know i'm
outside in front of a tank
uh getting my workout in all right
boy we got a hater of the week okay so
one of the things i was going to say uh
earlier with the tough mudder because
you know i
anytime i bring up haters it's always
going to be in the context of
like the patterns that i see and one of
the patterns that i love is when haters
have to lie
to try to get one up on me
and uh that's usually the case like
usually when they're coming at me it's
like oh you got these like basic facts
wrong so after the tough mudder
got like a bunch of random dms from you
know zero followers zero post uh you
know fake avatar
profiles like you didn't jump over the
obstacles i'm like uh what that's news
to me
and then i guess some random dude had
posted
a video where i'm like getting over you
know that the wooden bar thing
yeah like
i like jumped over it and like wobbled
on it because i'm like
several miles deep in the same like and
like i'm trying to figure out like do i
like just like jump over with my hands
or like straddle it and crush my nuts
and get over
um so like i like wobbled off of it i
was like oh i went to the other side and
i came off and like jumped over it again
so that was like one you know people
talking [ __ ] like you couldn't even get
over the dude chest high wooden beam on
the first time you're so unathletic you
just take so many steroids but you can't
even jump over a wooden beam
and i'm like oh but i did it like you
know again you're acting as if i
proclaimed myself like yeah i just
finished a tough mudder and
every obstacle i flew over in the first
attempt and it was super easy and i won
and i was the [ __ ] toughest of the
mutterest are you doing an impression of
me right there
because that was the case for me
but even you do like you're just like
yeah i finished ahead of everyone i'm
like i believe you
end of breath
you know um
but and then the second thing was there
was some like in this guy's video there
was some like you know the wall thing
that was just like a wall that you
jumped over right
now at this point my hands were freezing
like anything like involved grip i'd
like grip something like ah that's not
gonna work like let me try again so i
jump up and put my hands on and i'm
realizing like i can't even put pressure
on my hands to like push myself over
so i jump off and like
back away and then do it again but in
the meantime the guy doing his like
gopro filming like he caught that but
then like he goes up and like jumps and
like can't get over and he gets off and
like walks around it but like the way
he's like getting over it's like i'm to
his left and he's like filming to the
right so in that moment where he's
trying to get over i jump over the thing
like i jump over walls all the time it's
not a big deal
but uh
because i end up on the other side i
guess when the guy jumps over people
like you walked around him i guess i
jumped over like walked back 10 feet
just to like sprint again and like walk
around it but again these things don't
you know you're acting as if i bragged
like everything i did was super easy but
um
i did all the obstacles except that one
what was the one with like the
the hot dog thing right yeah yeah yeah
so there was one obstacle i didn't do
and if i didn't do any of them i would
tell you i'd be like yeah
i wanted to take it easy plus the hot
dog one like
it required no athleticism right yeah i
was like any test of like pride i was
like yeah i'm gonna do this just for the
sake of doing it um not gonna say it's
pretty or not gonna say it's easy or
that like i had the best technique going
over it but it's just funny how this
it's like oh like huh yeah something's
posted on reddit because 30 of you
idiots are telling me like i'm
unathletic despite taking steroids that
was like the big angle you know like all
the steroids and you can't even jump
over a wall the first time with frozen
hands oh my god
um
so that was all i set up to tell you
this one dude
was like talking [ __ ] on the youtube
page
going back and forth with me he had some
like his screen name it's always like
these people who are you know fake
screen name pick everything
the screen name was elon musk's baby's
fake name like
xae12 you remember that
so
he came in and actually he like started
talking [ __ ] to me
um
in a thread where like i had reconciled
with the guy which is always funny like
somebody's talking [ __ ] they're like
actually you're pretty cool i'm like
yeah thanks man like you're cool too
like one of those kind of things and
then he chimes in like without having
read all that and he's like yeah man
like you're so old and like you're
acting immature and just this like
standard narrative of like you're too
old to be arguing with people in the
youtube comments which is just i don't
believe in that it's like i'll converse
with anybody um and i don't think i
conduct myself like a kid but anyway
i said something to the effect of
hey man like you're a little off base
here i suggest you go do some research
about the situation or me in general and
come back to me and he mistook that for
like
not knowing what he's talking about like
in an academic sense of research and he
comes like the next comment he comes
back with is like oh actually i'm a
fifth year phd student studying uh
narcissism in males on social media
which is like
could be a thing like i've
had friends who studied like narcissism
in graduate school
um so it's not like i'm doubting that
like
as a thing that exists but i was like oh
interesting like
tell me more about this and we're like
we're going back and forth and i quickly
realized like
oh you're not an academic at all like
you don't have any reverence for the
truth and that always comes about
because people like i'm like you can't
even read and respond directly to what
i'm saying so anyway i kept challenging
this person like over and over i'm like
send me credentials like send me if
you're you know i'd be like well you're
not you're lying about having a phd so
like anything you say is totally
discredited
after like
so many comments they were finally like
i sent you a dm i sent you a dm and this
is like they hadn't sent me a dm and
then finally they were like i actually i
sent you dm and then i had my girlfriend
send you a dm
i'm like okay let me check my messages
and i get this message from this account
mia's smack talk
and also i know it's from the same guy
because he kept being like trying to
insult me like by saying
uh like mike or like marvin like that's
an insult to call me the wrong name
amazing great job dude if you have to
result you know rely on calling me like
you know markle or something like that
you've lost
so this guy sends me this thing from his
fake girlfriend's account saying my
boyfriend wants me to send you this
because you're ignoring his dms god
you're weird-looking just stop trying so
hard charlie i'm like oh there we go
charlie
so i look it up and it's like this
acceptance letter to boston college and
he had referenced like it's a school in
boston that i go to not the one you're
thinking but one that you'd know
and like the name is blacked out and all
that [ __ ] i'm like i
bet this is fake though so i google
boston college phd acceptance letter and
this is the first image that comes up
and i was just like oh my god you're so
bad at this you couldn't even have gone
to like the third one you know the third
google or the second page of google
results like you had to do this
and then i'm telling that to the person
who messaged me and they're like what i
don't even know who you are like i'm not
the person who's talking [ __ ] i'm just
some random person like reading this
comment thread 90 comments deep uh you
know so they couldn't even own up to
that
so this is the runner-up still because
you're just you failed at talking [ __ ]
to me and you failed a being hater
however there is an actual winner hater
of the week it's whoever decided to cast
this guy
kyle allen as he-man in the remake of
masters of the universe for netflix
because wtf like honestly
you're gonna you're gonna cast kyle
allen
over all this over this he-man right in
front of you this 23-year-old he-man
who's sitting in front of you flexing
his heart out for these roles
preparing his entire life putting on
muscle
year after year after year to be a a
human equivalent of the he-man cartoon
even having the ex you know if you want
me to do the bowl cut dye my hair blonde
and give that little bob i'll do it okay
i will become he-man for you
but she went with this doofus and i'm no
disrespect to kyle allen like you are
doofus obviously you were in west side
story i just don't know why him being in
west side story qualifies him for being
in he-man movie when i was in a cdw
commercial that's been seen by millions
of people all over the world okay so i
want you to think about those facts and
that reality and the fact that i play
stump on nickelodeon side hustle
and this guy was singing in a musical
and you think he's better qualified to
play he-man then
get your brain checked because it might
be suffering from dementia
unbelievable dude
like i don't want to take this
personally but it's like god damn
you're just you're you're bad at your
job
okay
this is the hello personality portion of
the podcast we are going to be looking
at enfj's today
is there a link yes i'm going to click
on it
oh hell yeah
the protagonist
i know a lot of enfjs enfjs are great
some of my best friends are enfjs mark
you say that about every personality
well it's true for the ones that i've
talked about so far
protagonists feel called to serve a
greater purpose in life
thoughtful and idealistic these
personality types strive to have a
positive impact on other people and the
world around them
they rarely shy away from an opportunity
to do the right thing even when doing
so is far from easy
protagonists are born leaders which
explains why these personalities can be
found among
notable politicians coaches and teachers
their passion and charisma allows them
to inspire others not just in their
careers but in every arena of their
lives including their relationships
a few things bring protagonists a deeper
sense of joy and fulfillment than
guiding friends and loved ones to grow
into their best selves
so
i've just found that to be true and i
wanted to talk about somebody who
recently
passed away a
guy named harrison shepard
he was uh the first boss i've ever had
he was this lawyer and i worked for him
as an assistant in the early 2000s after
i graduated from college at a time when
i didn't know what the hell i wanted to
do and even though he was a lawyer and i
actually had
um you know some idea that i maybe
wanted to go into a law because it's
kind of what you do with a liberal arts
degree and
you know your friends are all going to
law school and uh doing prestigious
things and here i am like pursuing you
know improv classes and thinking very
low of myself but he was somebody who at
the time was like dude you don't want to
be a lawyer
you want to be a performer and uh you
know we really connected over
movies we would go you know hang out
outside of work he was really cool in
that regard that he
was
a very much
enjoyed the role of mentor which i think
a lot of enfjs do
he was a lawyer and he was very ethical
he was probably the first lawyer i met
who would always talk about
ethics and doing the right thing and not
taking people's money
in litigation and instead preferring to
negotiate and
mediate situations because that's less
costly for the person involved and of
course if you didn't have any ethics
you'd want to be taking as much money as
possible from people who
came to you for your services so if you
go to court if you go to trial if you go
to uh you know litigation instead of
mediation that'd be costing a lot more
and harrison was just somebody who
um you know always had his eye on the
notion of what is right and wrong which
is
probably more rare than you'd think in a
lot of situations especially the
profession
of lawyering so he was probably the
first boss i ever had i was like i like
this person every job up to that point
that i'd ever had i was like i
immediately hate this within weeks and i
want to leave but i enjoyed harrison's
company
we kept in touch for many years after
i worked for him in the hate ashbury
and he was just always a an extremely
positive supportive and insightful
person who kind of one of those people
and i think enfj is are often like this
where like you'll
they'll ask you how you are
and listen so well that it's almost
shocking right they'll listen to you and
like uh-huh uh-huh tell me more in the
follow-up on certain threads and then
kind of
not give you advice per se but but give
you a synopsis of what you have told
them and say based on what you've told
me it sounds like this and kind of give
you an insight into your own emotional
landscape
that might have been previously
unavailable to you so
um
you know just want to give a shout out
to harrison really great guy who had a
positive impact on a lot of people and
lived a long life too he was a lifelong
smoker so of course that's gonna uh end
you know it takes some years off your
life but he did live well into his 80s
and he's survived by
a son
and
uh several grandchildren who are doing
great okay
i was gonna go to a hella psychedelic
story about this
um i'm gonna save it for next time
because there was this i'm gonna talk
about the first time i did lsd on the
next show because it involved harrison
and this guy that he took in
this homeless kid from slovenia
i want to tell the whole story but it's
getting a little long now and i want to
tell it in depth because this was
[ __ ] wild and uh it actually was a
terrible experience as far as doing the
actual drugs um
but you know it just goes to show you
you can't quit okay you can't just take
drugs once and not like them and decide
you're never going to do them again you
always got to give them that second
chance right so that was the first time
i did lsd i'm going to tell you about it
next time
and uh for now
i want to
i want to do
a quick celebrities are better than us
my buddy this is what i was asking casey
about before
did i do this segment already
celebrities are better than us the rock
somebody sent me my friend zach the
other day was like
uh sent me this dm of the rock doing
lunges with like two chains on his back
which probably equaled about 30 pounds
and i was like he's like oh my god the
rock works so hard and i'm like no he
doesn't the rock works out like a normal
bodybuilder i'm sorry but nothing you're
showing me in this video indicates any
sort of special work ethic plus the dude
is a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire i mean
he's got to have like tens if not
hundreds of millions of dollars this is
his job to be buff i'm not even going to
do a natty or not because it goes
beyond questioning that the guy's on
anabolics and i you know i know people
who know the guy who does his anabolics
of course he's on steroids there's no
question about it and he's on quite a
bit because you don't just suddenly
magically transform from being a sort of
muscular dude with a little bit of body
fat in your 20s and 30s to being
yeah 270 jacked with very little body
fat now is he disciplined with regards
to his diet allegedly because it you
know he according to him he's caught all
week like eight meals a day so
i can give him credit for that but as
far as
working hard in the gym there's always
this idea that like you can get
outworked in the gym and it's like dude
if you're working out too much it's to
your detriment okay you can get just as
big as the rock working out a few hours
a week
if you're taking the kind of steroids
that he's taking which i imagine
are
upwards of one to two grams of steroids
in total i don't know exactly what he's
taking i have no real desire to
um
speculate on that other than look at his
transformation
into his 40s and 50s that doesn't happen
naturally obviously but it also doesn't
mean that he's working out like six
hours a day you know you want to watch
me make a transformation like that and
just up all my dosages and get bigger
you know that's the only thing that
we're talking about because
somebody who's working out three hours a
day isn't going to get twice the results
as somebody working out an hour and a
half a day you work out smart
and you rest and you eat properly but
other than that you know there's this
whole mystique around like oh my god
celebrities worked out so hard to get in
shape it's like bro welcome to the world
of the gym there's dudes around you know
at every gold's gym at zoo culture like
this is not special it's called working
out and watching your diet you're gonna
get buff and if you're also famous in
buff i guess you get extra attention for
that but the idea that like celebrities
work so hard that's his job and most
bodybuilders who you see at the gym who
are super jacked are also doing other
[ __ ] you know i'm more impressed by a
guy who's doing hard labor
8 to 12 hours a day and also getting
jacked because that's going to be a lot
more physically and mentally taxing i
mean all the rock has to do is shoot a
few
movies each year and in the meantime he
has a private gym and he can afford to
get into any gym he wants and probably
rent it out to work out alone and have a
private chef that makes him all his
meals when you have money these things
become easier not harder so
the work that you're doing is like
anybody having a 40 hour work week he
doesn't spend 40 hours a week on his
body you know he probably spends a few
and then can pay people to do work on it
for him in the form of massages and and
you know help people
have people who he hires stretch him out
so
i got to say when you're looking at guys
like the rock and saying oh my god he
works so hard he's so special no he's
not he's a 50 year old bodybuilder who
happens to be incredibly famous and rich
not impressed okay
rant over
now i wanted to take a look at this guy
taian clark i said i was gonna go over
the hair protocol this week now this guy
is just freaking awesome he's actually
uh i think he's he's friends with leo
and longevity um
i'm getting my hair protocol from him
and actually haven't fully started this
yet because i've been collecting all the
things but
we're just going to look at his hair
protocol real quick okay emu oil
um
bio estro oil all these oils you can
like put together
um like a few drops of each and like rub
it on your scalp every night peppermint
oil is one thing i think this is also
swappable with rosemary oil
and then evening
primrose oil okay so those are all the
oils now you also got taurine
black currant oil in the form of
capsules
you got
active b complex you got
chromium gtf these are all things i've
been ordering off amazon by the way
zinc picolinate
optimized folate
grapefruit seed extract but i meant to
buy grape seed extract so that's my bad
you can just pretend that says grape
seed
vitamin k2 full spectrum
also
ketoconazole now there's this
ketoconazole shampoo that i've told you
about before that's like some
antifungals act as an antiestrogen or
anti
androgen if applied topically that makes
it so it like can stay on all night now
where do you get it because that's
actually ketoconazo
is something you need a prescription for
you can get it off ebay and there's also
some other like like uh
some prescription place that i'm going
to tell you about next week that i
forgot but like it looks kind of sketchy
because you're like i'm going to put in
this order for prescription thing that
uh may or may not come but i looked up
the
results from people actually ordering
from it and turns out it does come and
then finally micro needling okay so look
at all these things
you too
with only 80 products can regrow your
hairline but i'm going to give it a
whirl i'm going to give it you know a
fair shot
get into this goddamn routine of putting
80 things on my hair every night and and
taking 42 different pills
and if you see my hairline just popping
off like chewbacca
um
you're gonna know what's up okay
so finally
let's do a few this is why we can't have
nice gems just to wrap things up okay
boom let's click down there uh-huh we
got this one
what do we got here
this looks like it was just like set up
like a parody it's like but i feel like
this is real like i feel like these are
just random old dudes one guy who's like
humping the floor in blue briefs
super seductively like he's not doing an
exercise he's just like
stretching and this is in the middle of
you know what looks like a commercial
gym the guy next to him is bouncing up
and down on
uh at first i was like is that a little
trampoline but no it's one of those uh
soft uh blocks that you jump onto he's
just bouncing his apples up now which i
guess you could say is justified as like
a some sort of exercise like like a
squat you know but he's not coming all
the way up he's just like bouncing up
and down so this looks
weirdly like lemonparty.com if you've
never been there check it out now but
you know it looks like old dude gay porn
all right what's that next link
okay
175 kg for 19 reps now if you follow
power lifting you know there's like a
big controversy in
the rep ranges that people do on bench
press because they say you should like
it in various weight classes like the
solution to this which is like people
getting this grip all the way out here
and then the range of motion with a
crazy ass arch like this guy has i can't
even bend my back like that i mean the
range of motion is literally three
inches but he's doing it to competition
standards because his butt is on the
uh platform and
he's touching his chest and extending
all the way it's just whatever that is
350 so
that's about 385 pounds for 19 reps
and it travels a total
of you know 40 inches in all of those
reps
um
so
you know
but
that guy posted it in other words that
guy was like this looks cool i'm going
to brag about this by posting it online
and posting something
[Laughter]
boom three to five for 19 reps all right
and then we got this let's put the sound
on that
[Music]
oh some
buddy once told me so this girl goes to
do a medicine throw like a medicine ball
throw and just immediately hits herself
in the face bouncing that off the floor
now i kind of wonder i'm like did she
set that up because she dips into it
look at this
she like dips down on the floor which is
like you've never seen anybody like
squat after doing a medicine ball throw
so part of me is like did she mean to
hit herself in the face but people film
themselves doing the dumbest [ __ ] all
the time like unintentionally you know
like everybody's obsessed with filming
their workouts
i feel like she uh you know
you'd have to be like i'm gonna hit
myself in the face with this 30 pound
thing so i'm gonna give her the benefit
of the doubt and say you didn't mean to
do that
and you just [ __ ] your face up with a
medicine ball because
even the most basic movements like
medicine ball throws
some people can't figure it out because
you're not an athlete sorry
okay
guys i had more than i wanted to get to
today but of course i'm always
overzealous and i'm also drunk so you
know i don't have any sense of time
thank you for tuning in for another
banger of an episode we have a lot to
look forward to next week if i can get
some my some hand some if i can get some
hands on some dmt if i can get my hands
on some dmt we're gonna do it you're
gonna watch me freak the f out in studio
and we'll also try to take some other
substances i was gonna take some
nicotine gum today and just tell you how
i felt but i'm like do you wanna hear me
chewing gum the whole time probably not
now if you haven't already like
subscribe leave a comment for the algo
rhythm and also if you like this episode
this is the third one on the fitboy
network did you know that there are 17
other episodes available to you on
the haters will say podcast you gotta
type it in haters will say and then you
have 17 other whole episodes and you can
watch this entire journey from episode
one and you can also say mark how's that
back looking dude how's the 700
milligrams in angelo treating those lots
oh i don't know maybe maybe you can see
it like this just oh [ __ ] just gonna
ah oh my god wait is the sun being
blocked out or is mark glasses kind of
taking over and i don't know what to do